Everybody should have their owm theme music.
Hello everyone!
Alright!
If you don't follow me on Twitter you should
know it is not going to be a quite room.
Welcome to unintended consequences.
How ro reduce exclusionary practices in our
organizations and communities.
I am Kim Crayton.
You can use the hashtag #causeascene.
You can find me @KimCrayton1.
I have a website hashtagcauseascene.com as
well as kimcrayton.com.
After this I usually would put my credentials
in there, but you know what, I'm causing such
a scene, I don't care if you don't trust what
I have to say.
I know what I'm talking about.
So, there it is.
First, and also, there it is.
So, let's define some terms.
I am an educator by trade.
I entered tech four years ago.
I like to start everybody on the same page.
So that, when I get into my talk, people are
saying, yeah, I don't know what that means,
so we just start off everybody in the same
place.
Privilege is about access.
When I talk about privilege, I don't just
talk about race, and gender and all these
things, I talk about access, that means there
is a group of people who have more access
to resource s, connections, than other groups.
That's what privilege is.
It's that simple.
It's about access.
So I use this picture, because everybody,
people have seen these monkeys in Japan thinking
that's so cute.
What is there is an example of access, because
there's a family of female family group that
is only — they are the only ones who get
in the water.
The other monkeys on the outside, they've
got to fend for themselves.
If they freeze to death, they only freeze
to death.
It's only a family of monkeys that can get
in.
So this family has access to this pool of
hot water where others don't.
Under-represented is about numbers.
That's all it's.
In tech, white women are under represented.
Marginalised is about treatment.
In tech, many white women are not marginalised,
so I like to make that distinction because,
when people say they want diversity, adding
a white woman to your team, or to your panel,
is not diversity.
Diversity is about variety.
I know I'm from the States, and we have Crayola
crayons.
When you get that big box.
When I was a child, I got 64 crayons as an
own child.
That's what variety and diversity about.
Inclusion is the Holy Grail.
It is about experience.
It is about everyone having the experience
they expect when they come in contact with
your business, your community, or your event.
Inclusion is not about equity, because if
you white man and I, black woman from the
south of the United States, start the race
at the same time, you're still going to be
ahead of me.
I need you to stop, sit down for a second,
and let me catch up, and pass you!
Inclusion is not about quotas.
That's under representation.
Inclusion is about people's experiences with
your companies, your communities, and your
events.
So we're going to talk about some businesses
here, and these are some of the things that
get — that I find that get individuals in
trouble or get them in places you don't want
to be with these unintended consequences because
many people think they have a business when,
in fact, they have a product or a service.
A product or a service is not a business.
A business requires processes, policies, and
procedures that allow you to grow, scale,
recover, but for the fact that you have created
a product or service, you do not necessarily
have a business.
That's why BC can come in and take your company
because they bring in those scales that help
you grow and everything else.
And I blame the lean canvas model for this
because that is about iterating a product
or a service and not about a business.
Also, you cannot manage what you do not measure.
You can't.
You can get.
But you will never know where you are exactly
if you can manage it — you cannot manage
it if you cannot measure.
It.
I'm not a person who reads up these things.
These things appeared, because I don't remember
why, I ad lib a lot.
All too often, organisations fail, and, when
I say organisations, I mean businesses and
communities.
I'm going to make that one thing.
When I'm talking about organisations, that's
what I'm talking about, because, or become
toxic, because the leaders don't understand
that growth requires processes that enable
connectedness, innovation, and competitive
advantage.
What happens is you have a group of — we're
going to talk about white man because that's
what we are full of.
You have a group of white men who go to university,
who come up with this project, and this is
great.
Let's do this to make money.
They step over here with the same intelligent
hat when they're in their frat.
They have not thought about business being
different.
So they behave the same way.
They stay up the same amount of hours they
used to — that's why you have these Ping-Pong
tables — they have women and marginalised
groups, we couldn't care less about all that
— I'm going home — I don't even know how
to play Ping-Pong, I can't even keep it on
the table!
We don't — I'm not interested in drinking
beer with you on the job.
I want to do my job, and I want to go home.
Successful organisations are built on foundations
that enable their leaders to turn information
into knowledge in order to scale, evolve,
and recover.
That's what a business is.
If you can't scale it, if you can't recover,
or if you can't evolve, what you created for
yourself is a job.
It's not a business.
So you see people who work at restaurants,
and they can't ever leave.
They have to be there all day.
That's a job.
They created a job for themselves.
You want to be able to to work on your business
and not work in your business.
And so, is it we all know, being technologists,
Google has everything.
But just because you could find information
on Google does not mean it's knowledge for
you.
You have to do something to internalise that
information before it becomes knowledge, so
it's a lived experience.
That's one point they're missing.
The ability for organisation leads to successfully
create and manage operations relies heavily
on how well they are there are available and
necessary processes.
Here, we talked about that you have to have
the information that turns in the knowledge
that will allow you to scale, evolve, and
to recover, then you need to have the acumen,
the ability, to put those processes in place
to allow you to evolve, scale, recover.
I'm going to be honest with you: many of you
don't have these.
Many of you are developers.
Many of you don't care to learn anything else.
Like I say at many of my talks, if you don't
have these human-centric skills, you will
be out of a job soon, and you will be one
or the other.
I, on the other hand, who has a different
set of technical skills, you have technology
skills, I have a different set of skills,
I hate when they call my skills soft because
many don't have them, I am a person who can
deal with human beings, I will always have
a job.
You need to start thinking about that.
When leaders take the time to understand and
operationalise — this is a key word — operationalise
their organisation's functions, they avoid
common barriers to success while being able
to recover more quickly from unexpected events.
Unexpected events are going to happen.
As the first speaker talked about airs, we
know that's not in our code.
When you're building a business.
You're testing stuff out.
You think you have it, and there is your site's
down, or your accountant ran off with your
money — whatever it is.
There will be unexpected events.
Having these things in place allows you to
prepare at least for some of that.
Many businesses have no plans in place.
They're just going on, and whatever happens,
happens, and then they're just like, "I don't
know."
"I don't know why Cambridge Analytica has
our data.
I don't know why we didn't go back after four
years and did somebody check and see if they
destroyed that?"
I don't know all these things, because there
are processes in place.
Building a successful organisation with fewer
unintended consequences requires more than
a great product to serve — again, a product
— it requires leaders being able to give
all stakeholders — all stakeholders — the
experiences they want and the ability is to
manage a process.
This is where inclusion comes.
It's about experiences, and I'm going to tell
you what stakeholders I'm talking about in
just a moment.
I would like to talk to leaders because I
have nothing against people who are not in
leadership, but you have absolutely no power,
no agency, no resources, and you cannot move
these things forward, and what you do is you
become burnt out.
You become frustrated, because they are telling
you at the top that these things are important
to you but they're not giving you any resources
or backing so that you can do anything with
it, so you're banging your head against the
ceiling, and they're telling you are doing
such a great job but you feel guilty, I'm
tired, I want to be more inclusive — this
has to come from leadership.
When I talk about all stakeholders, I believe
building businesses for social change.
We are in a time where everybody has access
to information.
We are at a time where pretty — a lot of
people are very polarised.
And I can speak from the United States.
I don't want to make any assumptions about
Germany, but I know our government is not
run by politicians, it's run by business owners.
It is run by very wealthy business owners
who can pay lobbyists to give money to politicians,
and politicians in turn maybe decisions based
on the money they received.
So, when we talk about — when I say all
stakeholders, in a traditional business, it
is just about as shareholder.
This is what gets me, because people get upset
about jobs leaving.
I'm going to give you some business education
if you don't know this.
In the United States — again, don't know
about Germany — it is illegal for a board
of directors, or a CEO, their first priority
has to be shareholder value.
So, if they do something or make a decision
that would not bring the shareholders as much
money as possible, they can be sued by said
shareholders.
So, I found ed it — I found it quite interesting
that, during the previous election, all these
people — coal jobs are gone, they ain't
bringing them back.
The carrier, they thought they were going
— those jobs weren't going to go to Mexico.
I don't care who trump is, or who everybody
else is, the shareholders of that company
own that company, and the CEO and the board
of directors have to do whatever they can
to make sure that shareholders are not only
not losing money but are increasing their
profits.
That's what shareholders are about.
Stakeholders are looking at other people in
the company, and this is where you get the
inclusiveness.
If you're only thinking about shareholder
value, how inclusive can you actually be?
That's why there's no money in it because
you can't justify — there is data about
ROI return on investment when you have a very
inclusive teams, and I'm sure if you work
on inclusive teams, you know that you have
better ideas, you can create better, you can
create something together that you couldn't
create by yourself, but if your main thing
is about shareholder value, if giving something
to inclusion and diversity and those shareholders
don't see an immediate return on their value,
you're not going to get that money.
So we're talking about stakeholder values.
This is what the business model I believe
in, and it's talking about considering those
who work for you, those who partner with you,
those who buy from you, and those who invest
in you.
I have them in that order for a reason.
Your employees, the people who work for you
are your most important asset.
Period.
They determine how any customer experience
is going to be.
So you need to make sure that you have thought
about how to improve the experiences of those
internal stakeholders.
And then you're going to go outside a bubble,
and those are your partners, maybe your supply
chain, if you're making T-shirts, the company
you choose to make your T-shirts, these are
the things that you need to think about because
you might pick a company that has policies
that you don't believe in.
But you partner with them because you haven't
thought about these things.
Also, who buys from you?
Everybody's not going to buy from you.
There are some clients you will not want,
but you can't know that or be able to articulate
that well if you have not made these determinations,
or if you haven't thought about these things.
Everybody is running out here for this VC
money.
Mail chimp was named — number-one company
for 2017, and they've not taken a bit of venture
capital money before before when we talk about
investing, we need to think, when we are talking
about communities, your local JavaScript,
who is investing their time in you?
Who is sponsoring you?
Those are the four stakeholders you need to
think about.
Going from a product to service focus to business-model
focus takes time.
You've got to stop expect ing simple solutions
to complex problems.
This is what gets us in trouble.
It takes intention which means I want to do
something, but wanting to do it is not enough.
You have to have a strategy in place to make
it happen.
All are necessary in order to innovate, differentiate,
and compete in the information age.
You do not have a business if you cannot,
not in the information aiming, if you cannot
innovate and differentiate yourselves.
There are two ways you can get competitive
advantage through differentiation, and price.
I don't think anybody really wants to battle
anybody on price.
When you differentiate your services and products,
you can, this is really something, look at
Louis Vuitton, nobody needs one of those bags
but I see tons of them.
All you need is a sack from the grocery store,
but people have different ideas of what they
value.
Building stakeholder focus is a proactive
approach to addressing inclusion to diversity.
Woof to have a plan.
It has to be strategic because, when we don't
do that, underrepresented and marginalised
individuals are harmed by our actions.
This is the reason I have a problem with stack
overflow today.
I have a serious problem that, for the last
three years, their survey indicates that 92
per cent of their survey participants were
white males between the ages of 18 to 34.
White males between the ages of 18 to 24,
you're my target audience because you're the
bottleneck.
You're in the way.
There is nothing wrong with you, I have nothing
against you.
But you are in the way.
What I don't like about the stack overflow
issue is the fact that businesses are looking
at that as if that is a representation of
the global community.
It is not.
It's a representation of those individuals
who feel safe enough to engage and gamify
stack overflow.
[Cheering and Applause].
I'm currently hearing that people are going
on interviews and asking, "I need to see your
GitHub and stack overflow score."
What?
What does that have about me doing my day
to day job.
Because women, people of colour, people with
disabilities, are not actively engaging on
stack overflow, they don't have scores.
It means these decisions by business leaders
are impacting us financially.
And you really don't have a right to mess
up my money.
Is so stop making these stupid decisions.
So I'm going to take you from a process shifting
from a product or service focus to a business-model
focus.
Step one.
I have now know clients imagine — imagine
what the ideal stakeholder experience would
look like.
I don't have my clients talk about their product
or service until several sessions later, because
that doesn't matter.
If you do this part right, you can pivot,
change, do everything.
You should not be married to a product or
service.
That's also what gets us in trouble, because
we can't change it, and even though our customers,
all of our stakeholders are not saying this
is working for me, stack overflow, you're
holding on to this, and those who follow me
know that I'm into stack overflow right now,
so I have a problem because they — is the
hub in the wheel?
The hub of every developer community in the
world.
You cannot tell me, especially when we're
talking about AI machine-learning and deep-learning,
that that code on that website is not biased.
So, you have people who don't feel safe enough
to engage on that site, so they copy and paste
the code.
At some point, there's going to be a tipping
point where we have a problem.
So this process is not outlining, not outlining,
so you're not saying step one, step two, you
really want to get into the feel how you want
your customers to feel when they come in contact
with your organisation.
It's not about product or services at this
point.
What do you want them to feel when they come
in contact with you?
When they reach out to you and say, "I need
help, because," how do you want them to feel
through the whole process?
And this takes time.
Some clients I have recently thought it was
going to be because they're in El Salvador
thought it would take them a few hours.
It took them a week to get their assignment
back to me, because you really have to think
deeply about this.
It's time for you to tap into the emotions.
We go back to Louis Vuitton.
The only reason why people buy it is because
there's an emotional attachment to that — that's
what high-priced goods are, they elicit an
emotion in us.
You want to use adjectives, descriptive words.
This is ago an example I'm going to give you.
You have to create indicators.
So this is me.
Oops.
Yes.
So, define.
So my company, you want to put a company name,
it has a commitment to.
Kim Crayton has a commitment to positive change
in the technology sector.
Anybody who follows me knows that is what
I do.
So now you want to define your core values.
My company is to promote positive organisational
and community change in fun and engaging ways.
That's why I have the music, conferences and
shirts.
This stuff is hard enough.
I need people to feel safe and comfortable,
and welcome to have these challenging, complex
conversations.
So you want to know what that looks like,
what that experience looks like.
Then you want to define your indicators.
For me, it is to get more clients, so that
means to me, I will know that I have more
clients because I'm meeting or exceeding my
monthly financial goals.
I'm getting attention because I have a significant
growth in brand awareness.
I'm getting more Twitter followers, for Instagram
followers, getting people say do you want
to be on my podcast?
And then I want data.
I want to track client outcomes, so when I'm
working with my personal clients, I want to
make sure I provide them with a simple thing
— a testimonial.
All they have to do is fill in the blanks,
at my conferences, a survey or something.
I want to get that data.
Then you want to apply it.
You want to apply measurements.
You cannot manage what you can not measure
this X number of dollars per months by December
31st.
Get attention.
Be a guest on X number of podcasts, or write
in X number of publications by this time,
and I will identify that.
And give data.
X number of testimonials, referrals, sponsorships.
These are things that I have identified so
that I can measure myself against it.
So then I ask myself: what must we must we
have reach this benchmark to know that we
claim success.
We can't say I got halfway there because you're
not measuring.
I say got halfway there but these are the
reasons I only got halfway there, so this
may be a success.
You maybe only got halfway there because you
had to pivot ahead and be a more successful
opportunity but you will not know that if
you haven't sat down and written these things
out.
This step is where a deep — where you develop
effective metrics for measuring your core
values.
So, my core values again are to promote positive
organisational community change in fun and
engaging ways.
This is how you turn — because people like
how do you get these adjectives.
This is why code of conducts don't work all
the time, because "be nice" — what does
that mean?
Everyone has a different idea of what be nice
is.
You need to figure out words that are measurable.
I also don't like "harassment", because if
you've not defined it in the beginning, some
people have a different idea of what harassment
is.
That would lead to the MeToo movement.
Then you want to test the indicators with
your stakeholders, and you want to collect
data interest them data are the facts, but
again, that's not enough.
You want their feedback, their feelings, and
their reactions, so it is two ways of collecting
data.
You want to collect information, so you want
to get that hard data, that quantitative data,
but you also want to get that qualitative
data, because, without both, you do not have
a complete picture.
And then you want to evaluate your measurements
to determine if your benchmarks are not met.
This is where people mess up.
You want to know why, if you did meet — what
did you do?
Write that stuff down.
If you did not talk about it and write that
stuff down.
Use knowledge from evaluation and testing
to refine the process, and you're going to
iterate, and tell people as you iterate your
product or service, you need to be iterating
your culture and values, need to be testing,
figuring out is this working for you do we
need to change that?
You need to be doing it just like a sprint.
And then you need to standardise it.
Once you have something that's concrete, a
little, I mean, more concrete, because it's
never going to be concrete, you need to create
former processes on the knowledge from the
evaluations, you need to adopt explicit language
and explicit things you can write documentation.
Documentation is the best ways, one of the
first ways that you can be more inclusive
in your communities.
You need to be writing documentation, in particular
if you have customers that use that to create,
or use that to answer questions, your documentation
is not a one-stop thing, it is a continuous
cycle.
You need to share tacit knowledge.
Tacit knowledge is what you turn information
into personal knowledge, and so, if I'm doing
something, and I have a task, and I've done
it a few times, now I have my own way of doing
that.
You need to not only capture that but that
needs to be shared throughout the organisation,
because in an information economy, it is that
tacit knowledge that will allow you to differentiate
and be competitive if the . Not this book
knowledge or these binders.
That's not the information you need that's
going to make you competitive.
Core values should be inform all organisational
decisions, and we're going to show you what
I mean in a minute.
Remember that this is an ongoing process.
The decisions that are the result of this
process should be seen, not seen as immutable
or rigid.
Organisation of leaders should plan to re
view whether stakeholders factors have changed,
at least, at a minimum, two times a year,
because you need to be shifting.
When leaders create organisations around well-defined
and tested core values that consider the needs
of all stakeholders, and have processes in
place to monitor progress, again, it is all
stakeholders' measurements, they are less
likely to discover at some point in the future
that they've been nurturing a toxic environment.
This is my first example.
What I talk about my core values, what are
the changes of this community in a positive
way, and a fun way, right?
The first example, this fits into my core
values.
I have Cause a Scene merchandise.
It's — I'm going to be honest with you,
I don't ever remember what I said in my talks.
So people come back and say, "You sound like
that's good, I'm going to write that down."
So I have several items on this website, because,
again, I have a problem with people not wanting
to pay for this.
I just like you go to work every day, you
expect a cheque, the things I do, I expect
to get paid for.
The second example — yes, wooh!
Exactly.
The second example is the conference.
So the conference is all about — again,
I'm an educator, and a special needs certified,
so I'm used to working with students to demonstrate
how to do something.
So I'm really sick and tired of people talking
about, "We can't find underrepresented and
marginalised people to speak at our conferences."
You don't have an excuse any more because
I'm showing you how to do it.
Again, my conference is Monday night, I'm
sorry, I use the English thing, because I
informed you think I'm talking 7.30 in the
morning.
Heck, no.
It's 7.30 pm until 11 pm.
It's not in the morning.
The next example of me using my core values
to make decisions is my podcast.
Just launched on Wednesday, this past Wednesday.
It is the raw deal Holyfield.
We're talking about everything, because we
need to have these conversations so we can
move through them been it's not until we have
the challenging conversations, and white men,
I'm going to tell you: if you're feeling uncomfortable,
you're only feeling this much discomfort.
I walk around in this every single day.
If I can deal, you can.
[Cheering and Applause].
And the fourth example is the leadership training,
the coaching that I'm doing, I'm doing some
consulting while I'm here.
And this is — I'm doing — so this is also
showing you and giving you a demonstration
of how I've used my core values to dictate
how I get so my stakeholders and my customers.
So, thank you.
[Cheering and Applause].